Dr peterson,
I'm considering going into the education stream slash system.
Do you have any advice for me not to become a mouthpiece for indoctrinating
young students?
Well,
one thing I would recommend is that you don't write essays that you don't
believe in.
I think that's a sin.
I think it's a sin to use your words falsely and the reason for that,
like there's a good series of social psychology experiments that show,
like imagine that you bring someone into a lab and you have them write an essay
about or fill out a questionnaire about their political opinions so you get a
baseline measure of their political stance and then you ask them to write a
thousand words.
Maybe they identify as right,
wait,
and then you get them to write a thousand word essay on why a particular left
wing position is true,
and then you have them come back in two weeks and you give them the same
political belief questionnaire they'll tell have shifted quite radically towards
the left.
And the reason for that is that people don't think through their positions in
great detail,
and so if you get them to think through a contract position in great detail,
then that starts to become more convincing.
And so if you go into a field like education that's really pathologically
overrun by the postmodern,
neo Marxist types,
you're going to experience a tremendous amount of pressure to falsify your
words.
You're going to be afraid that if you don't do that,
you're going to fail.
And maybe sometimes you will be punished by a professor.
But I would say in most circumstances,
I'm still optimistic enough to believe that if you write a good essay that isn't
ideologically proper,
you'll still get a good grade.
I guess I would say if you write a good essay that's not ideologically proper
and you don't get a good grade,
that's probably a good time to fight.
So because you either fight or capitulate,
right?
That's,
that's the.
That's the hard truth.
So I'm not saying it would be easy and I would also say don't make unnecessary
enemies,
right?
You don't.
Everything doesn't have to be a battle.
Now.
And then you're going to know that,
you know,
you'll hate writing the essay because you have to sacrifice your soul in order
to put the words down and then you,
you,
you demand and warp your character and you just don't recover easily from that.
So I would say,
don't do that,
man.
That's not good.